moi je m'en vais vous vous vous commencé
mon tour par une histoire qui j'espère
va vous faire rire serait l'histoire de
ça je me marre des gens dans la salle
histoire va français qui racontera nom
anglais et qui lui fait du yo-yo poil
lui même face à enfin s'est pas rendue
you do you de poil ça veut dire comme on
va toujours pas le mémoire de gérard et
en anglais parce que ça aille plus
moderne
je trouve que c'est un peu drôle de
faire ça et puis ils ont trié pour être
un toit nos dates en avant c'est à dire
que avant au désert et toile à matelas
mais avec la démocratisation du camping
quand plus à équivoque première toile
enfin l'importance c'est que de pouvoir
parce que voyez vous ce qu'il ya
d'important dans la commune car l'heure
actuelle ah bah ça doit savoir évoluer